hey guys what's up so if you didn't spot
it there was a really big reverse-flash
easter egg during the Justice League
trailer so I'm gonna explain what's
going on if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I do Marvel and DC every week there's
even a special flash ring giveaway going
on I'll explain at the end of the video
the reverse-flash Easter egg in the
Justice League trailer is almost a non
moment if you blinked you might have
missed it because each of the characters
get like a little bit filling out their
backstories so obviously we have all the
solo movies that are happening Justice
League is the team up movie but for each
of the different characters there are
supporting casts like Aquaman has Mira
in the trailer so Barry Allen interacts
with a couple of characters that are
going to show up during the flash movie
even though they're rewriting that I'll
explain that too that's kind of a
separate issue but Henry Allen is being
played by dr. Manhattan himself maybe
that explains why his lightning is blue
that's not the reason there's been a lot
of talk about the color of the Flash's
lightning that's also kind of a separate
design issue but I do think it's really
interesting so we can talk all about is
lightning eventually but Henry Allen is
in prison in the comics in almost every
version of every flash story that we've
ever seen because he's been falsely
accused of the murder of Nora Allen
Barry's mother if you haven't been
reading the comics recently flash
rebirth has been great so far so I
recommend that you check it out last
year in the first issue we meet Henry
Allen and very sort of narrates in his
own head some of his history sort of
like catching people up that have never
read the flash comic before talking
about how his mother was murdered
referencing the reverse flash eobard
thawne but the big thing about the flash
movie in the Justice League DC EU is
that because we haven't had the flash
movie yet we don't know how close
they're going to stick to the comics we
don't know what the story of the flash
movies going to be there have been a
couple hints before but they've since
been through about two different
versions that we know about of the
script and now a third one is being
worked on mostly because they'd gone
through different directors and they
kind of sort of like the creative
Renaissance under Geoff Johns so there's
a whole bunch of flash stuff going on
behind the scenes but we're going to see
this scene during Justice League so you
get more context for how the
reverse-flash fits into this universe
most of you probably seen at least a
little bit of the TV show so you know
that they use this as the basis for the
plot of season 1 learn
who the man in the yellow suit was that
was even the name of one of the episodes
where they revealed who it was my father
went to prison for her murder then an
accident made me the impossible and one
day I'll find who killed my mother and
get justice for my father
I don't want to kill you Barry I need
you to face each other again very soon
the oh my god moment probably one of my
favorite moments from season one was
when he revealed his name my name is
eobard thawne so there was any doubt
they are not going to leave the greatest
flash villain of all time
completely out of the DC EU but because
Barry Allen suit served as the basis for
the reverse-flash making his suit like
he copied the Flash's suit when he made
it you do wonder if he's going to have
that tech based armor look that Barry
Allen has in the DC EU easiest way to
talk about it would be just call it the
injustice armor but it seems like Bruce
Wayne is going to use some of his money
like you said that's his secret power
what's your superpower again I'm a rich
to clean up Barry's homemade suit
because the way Zack Snyder explained it
when we first learned about Barry odd
was that he had cobbled it together from
a leftover NASA parts you have to
imagine that the high speeds that he
moves that even though the Speed Force
should allow him to break the laws of
physics he still encounter so much force
that he has to use parts that are
designed for space shuttles that are
meant to withstand the intense pressures
when you're moving at speeds that space
shuttles move when they're re entering
or leaving orbit as for reverse-flash
story what they'll probably do is take a
similar approach to the TV show in the
Aquaman movie so the way Jason Momoa
talks about the Aquaman movie is a good
template for the other spin-off movies
for the characters so what he said is
that it's a look at where he's been
where he is right now and where he's
going meaning that you're going to learn
about the origin story because when we
see him in Justice League he's already
going to be king of Atlantis when we see
the flash he's already become the flash
because he's seen all the footage he's
like okay
clearly you're very fast we need you on
the team so we'll meet some of his
characters maybe we'll get a flash of
his origin story him getting hit by the
bolt of lightning but most of that will
be addressed in the flash movie when we
event
please see it it might actually be 2019
before we see that movie because there
are two movies that Warner Brothers is
going to try and shoot this year in the
flash movie is not one of them if you
haven't read a lot of flash comics the
original version of the story the
reverse flash always tries to hurt Barry
Allen because he can't kill him directly
because he needs Barry Allen to become
the flash so that he can later become
the flash because he got some of his
Speed Force powers by reverse
engineering things that Barry Allen had
done from his costume from his flash
ring so if Barry Allen never became the
flash then the reverse flash would have
never learned about that could have
never become the evil speedster that he
is today
so Barry Allen is the one thing that he
can't get rid of but he can kill anybody
in Barry Allen's life make him as
miserable as possible in the original
Silver Age version of the story if
you've heard about the trial of the
flash comic it's the seminal story about
how Barry Allen goes on trial because he
kills the reverse-flash that was because
he was getting ready to kill iris Allen
who was dressed up in Batgirl cosplay
you may have seen this panel he's not
killing Batgirl here he's actually
killing iris Allen cosplaying at a
Halloween party
as Batgirl so when the reverse slash
comes back around Barry Allen's like no
not again he snaps his neck and down
goes eobard thawne so flash goes on
trial and even though you don't see her
anywhere in the trailer iris Allen will
also be in the Justice League movie they
cast Kiersey Clemons if you're not
familiar with her she was best in
neighbors to sorority rising so she can
do comedy really well she has a nice
energy about her she was in a dope which
is a little bit more of a serious drama
movie which is basically what all flash
stories are heavy drama cut with a lot
of humor so it'll be a preview of what
the flash movie might feel like but
remember it's going to be a different
director different script same actors
though they're not going to recast any
of these people for the flash movie then
later more of you probably familiar with
flashpoint Jeff donned reimagined that
idea only this time instead of killing
his wife he goes back in time to kill
Barry Allen's mother
so Barry says enough is enough he goes
back saves earth but creates the
flashpoint timeline which is what the
reverse-flash wanted him to do I am the
answer to all your prayers all you need
to do is ask me Barry
we need to go back in time until that
night to do what you know what I need
you to do yeah but I want to hear you
say I need you to kill one mother
with pleasure I hate you god I wish I
could kill you what's today I get to be
the hero so because this push-pull story
of the reverse-flash not being able to
kill Barry Allen in Barry Allen not
being able to save his mother a lot of
the consequences of that are playing out
on the TV show during season three
so they're actually dealing with that
via this avatar plotline and what's
going to happen tonight is I'll post
that new episode supposedly they're
going to reveal his identity they may or
may not do that but that's what they've
been teasing in the trailer so let me
know in the comments what do you think
the reverse-flash is going to look like
in the DC EU and what do you want them
to do with him in the flash movie
because originally like in the scripts
that had been thrown out it was the
Rogues that were going to be the big
bads but now it sounds like they're
going with something that's a little
more comic book centric it sounds like
one of the reasons why some of the
previous directors left is because they
wanted to do things with the characters
there were a bigger departure from the
comics than the studio wanted to go but
they wanted to change a lot of things
about the comic book characters in ways
that would make them very much not like
their comic book self that's where Jeff
John scoops in and tells new directors
who aren't familiar with the comics know
Barry Allen does not have a nose ring no
no he isn't super hardcore and edgy he
is the heart and soul of the Justice
League this is his back story this is
why he makes decisions certain ways so
whatever the flash movie ends up being I
think it'll be a lot more comic-book
accurate than it would have been before
so all good things but there is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway going
on all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll announce the winner when I post my
flash episode later tonight so be sure
to watch the episode while you wait for
that to post you can click here for more
Justice League and you can click here
for that spider-man trailer thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video
you